الصين ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم ولاعب
اساسي في الاقتصاد العالمي تخوض طموحا
بحريا متصاعدا يواجهم خوف امنيه خارجيه
استراتيجيه بكين الاقتصاديه لا تقتصر على
الاستثمارات الماديه فالخط الواضح الذي
تنتجه الصيني يتمثل باستخدام مزدوج
للموانئ الخارجيه
الشركات الصينيه قامت بتوسيع استثماراتها
في الموانئ الاجنبيه في السنوات الاخيره
بحسب مجله ايكونو ميسي
2010 و 2020 استثمرت الصين ما يصل الى 20
مليار دولار في الموانئ الاجنبيه حيث
تمتلك حصصا في عقود ايجار او امتيازات في
95 ميناء اجنبيه وفقا بحثا من الكليه
الحربيه البحريه الامريكيه وجامعه انديانا
فيما مرت اكثر من سبعه وعشرين بالمئه من
تجاره الحاويات العالميه العام الماضي عبر
محطات تمتلك فيها شركات الرائده في الصين
وهون كونج حصصا مباشره اما معركه الصين
فكانت في المانيا بعد ان سمحت الحكومه
الالمانيه لشركه كوسكو الصينيه بشراء حصه
تبلغ نحو 25% في مرفا بهمبرج الذي يعد
اكبر موانئ البلاد امر اثار حينها عاصفه
من الانتقادات والتساؤلات حول دوافع
القرار الالمانيه فسرت الصفقه انا ذاك
بانها جزء من سلسله صفقات صينيه تستهدف
السيطره على قطاعات من البنيه التحتيه
الاوروبيه بهدف استكمال مبادره الحزام
والطريق التي ترمي الى احياء طريق الحرير
الصينيه القديمه اما الولايات المتحده
فترى من تمدد الصين بشبكه الموسعه في
موانئها اجنبيه مؤشرا على وجود مخاوف عده
منها ما يتعلق باكتساح الصين سوق البضائع
العالميه وان تستخدمها كثره للوصول
لمعلومات حول نقاط ضعف في سلسله توريد لدى
المنافسين الا ان المخاوف الامنيه تاه هي
الهاجس الاول واشنطن حيث يمكن ان تسهل
الاستثمارات الصينيه في ثواني اجنبيه
الطريقه امام بكين خدمه الجوانب العسكريه
البحريه لها دون الحاجه الى بناء نظام
قواعد متطورا بشكل سريع وهو امر تنفيه
الصين رافضه تسسيسه طموحها الاقتصاديه
روان حمزه العربيه